With film rights spread across three different
studios, Marvel Comics is omnipresent in the
realm of comic book movies.
Just in 2014, fans got four films from three
companies, giving them plenty of opportunities
to see their favorite heroes on-screen.
More often than not, these flicks are full
of memorable characters we can’t wait to
see in sequels.
Here are Screen Rant’s 5 Favorite Marvel
Movie Heroes.
Star-Lord
A couple years back, few even knew who Star-Lord
was, but now the Guardians of the Galaxy protagonist
is one of the leading figures of the MCU.
Peter Quill’s admiration for Earth’s pop
culture and strong emotional connections to
his home planet (and lack of real super powers)
makes it easy for audiences to relate to him.
He’s just an ordinary guy thrown in extraordinary
situations.
Plus, he has a Han Solo-esque charming rogue
streak about him thanks to the performance
by Chris Pratt.
A thief with a heart of gold, Star-Lord has
endeared himself to the masses and will be
around for a long time.
Professor X
Everybody needs a mentor, and those who attend
Charles Xavier’s School for Gifted Youngsters
have one of the finest around in Professor
X. Patrick Stewart was every X-Men fans’
dream choice for the role, and his performances
in several films showcased why.
He brought forth many of the qualities we
love about the character, including his compassion
and strong desire to make the world a better
place.
Xavier is also a phenomenal teacher, giving
frightened mutants a place to call home as
they learn to master their gifts.
He was even able to connect with Wolverine.
It’s too bad the quality of the films wasn’t
always at the level of Stewart’s talents.
Blade
Long before Marvel and DC adaptations flooded
theaters, the Blade trilogy first showed how
live-action comic book films could be a viable
investment.
Much of their success was due to star Wesley
Snipes, who injected the titular character
with a sense of cool composure that made him
fun to watch in several breathtaking action
sequences.
Blade’s confident bravado made him stand
out from the crowd and illustrated why he’s
a valuable ally in a fight.
Also, Blade has a deep sense of honor, choosing
to use his half-vampire abilities to protect
humans instead of preying on them.
That alone makes him a worthwhile hero.
Wolverine
When a movie’s hero is an indestructible
killing machine, viewers criticize it as boring.
But that’s never been a problem with Hugh
Jackman’s Wolverine.
Thanks to the actor’s unwavering love and
enthusiasm for playing the character over
and over again, Logan has struck a chord with
audiences.
His rugged toughness and fierce sense of loyalty
are traits we love to see in any hero, and
the mysteries about his past add layers of
emotional complexity and vulnerability to
the character – making him an interesting
watch.
When Jackman faces his inevitable “retirement”
from the part, it will be a sad day indeed.
Iron Man
The poster boy of the MCU, RDJ’s Tony Stark
is a rock star that has endeared himself to
fans all across the globe.
His charming wit, high intellect, and smooth
sarcasm make him something of a comic book
James Bond – in that many people would happily
sign up to be him if they had the chance.
But there’s more to Stark than his snark.
Over the course of the films, he’s learned
the value of selflessness and what it takes
to be a hero, showing that despite his narcissistic
moments, he truly cares about the world.
All in all, he’s a fascinating character
to follow, and it will be interesting to see
how he evolves down the line.
Those are our picks for our five favorite
Marvel movie heroes.
Are there any we missed?
Who are some of your favorites?
Let us know in the comments section below
and subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!